- I love your outfit!
I asked her, she did a "get ready" video,
like coming out here.
- Always.
- Okay, I cannot wait to see this.
You have six million followers.
- Yes.
- That's incredible.
Okay, so explain "get ready with me."
Did that just-
you were just doing it for fun and then
it ended up becoming
like a segment almost?
- Yeah, so on TikTok, you can do like
a livestream video and I would always
do those before I was going out and
those videos would get way more views
and way more traction than my-
oh, oh my gosh.
- [Kelly] There you are.
(Alix giggles)
- They would get more views than
the videos I was posting on TikTok,
so I was like, "you know what,
why don't I just turn
these getting ready videos
into a TikTok video?"
And they just took off.
It's crazy to me.
I guess people are just interested,
and I do my makeup while I'm kind of
talking about where I'm going
or what's going on and
a lot of it would be
me at the University of Miami,
night life in Miami, what is Miami like,
and I think it's just a crazy universe
down in Miami so people were just
so interested and took off from there.
- I like, though, when you-
I think breaking down the wall, that's the
reason why people get into it, as well,
because people like to see people
that are relatable, I think.
- Yeah.
- Well, one of Alix's "get ready with me"
posts that went viral -
oh, this is amazing -
was her getting ready for
a Miami Dolphins game.
So let's see that.
I love it.
- I have this tiny little Jimmy Choo bag,
which I think goes with the heels.
Feel like a mom picking
up her kids from school.
(audience cheers)
- I'm like.
I love that you think a mom
could look that together
picking up-
I know, it's amazing.
So the moms, they came out.
- The moms humbled me very quickly.
They were like, "girl."
- [Kelly] Yep, yep.
Yeah.
This is on the way to school.
This is them on-
(Kelly laughs)
Okay.
So this is me after-
yes, yeah.
This is, you see the-
(audience cheers)
This is me.
This is after sleeping with your children
and they kick you all night
and it's super fun.
No, my goal is to look like you
in that video at some point.
So wait, so you have a new podcast.
This is like a new realm for you,
so do you like it?
Are you enjoying it?
- I love it.
It's been a learning process for sure.
You know, 'cause when you're
talking for two minutes
in a TikTok video and now I'm talking for
two hours for one episode to come out,
it's very different and I think people are
getting to see a different side of me
or just learning so much about me
that they didn't know before and, I mean,
there's many more stories to come.
- Does it stress you out
to be that vulnerable?
'Cause it's a little more
in-depth, I feel like,
the podcast.
- Yeah, so right before I
launched the first episode,
I was freaking out.
I was like, "I don't think I can do this,
I'm so stressed," because
the more you tell people,
the more room there is
for criticism and stuff,
but the reason I feel comfortable with
sharing my life online is just that
I feel like I'm kinda
directing the narrative of it
and I'm okay with people not liking me
if they don't like who I am, yeah.
It's a little bit more frustrating when
there's false stuff out there,
and then I'm like-
- It's so frustrating!
- But it's important to me to kind of
help the younger audience
that's watching me, too.
I wish I had someone who was kinda of
showing their acne or telling about
getting cheated on, you
know, all that stuff
to look up to when I was younger, so I-
- [Kelly] And to connect to, yeah.
- Hopefully setting a good example.
- Yeah, well, good luck with it.
Six episodes in, that's really awesome.
- [Alix] Thank you.
- Yeah, it is a lot of work, I heard.
That's why I don't wanna do one.
(audience and Alix laugh)
We did the math, though, and during the
course of just this segment, Alix has
gained over 5,000 followers, so just now.
It just happened.
(audience cheers)
It's amazing.
Let's do a commercial break, everybody!
You can listen to "Hot
Mess" with Alix Earle
every Thursday on Spotify.